[Music]
[Applause]
that is a sneak peek of the upcoming
carpool karaoke spinoff series James
Corden gave his audience just a little
taste last night on The Late Late Show
if you notice Gordon's not in the car
they kicked him to the curb but it's
okay because Jada pinkett-smith Queen
Latifah Regina Hall and Tiffany Haddish
had things under control they star in
the hilarious new movie girls trip I
really do think this is this summer's
bridesmaids or bad moms and I was first
on the set down in the Big Easy
that's a slick ass all day all day all
day have a good evening lady yeah
Jada does some slain Queen V style in
New Orleans as she bonds with another
Queen Latifah
jada and Latif are real-life friends but
haven't been together in a movie since
robbing banks back in 1996 is set it all
you need to Viktor Bout
face how's it you'll be back together so
good have fun yeah so much nice being
with her on screen I realize that why we
waited so long why did you wait so long
oh yeah we were working that's true you
know things get crazy for the foursome
which includes Regina Hall and Tiffany
Haddish during you guessed it a girls
trip you gonna see some dance baggage
battles
you gonna see some so some grown some
brews Oh your brother Bobby said I don't
have some grown bang some ziplining that
go yeah yeah really okay the Bourbon
Street yeah this is a lot yeah anything
could pop off at any moment
I'm not forget pregnant